the American Embassy was like the symbol
of American imperialism right in the
center of Tehran
history foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I gave up my weapon a blindfold me I
thought it was it for me
the American Embassy in Tehran is in the
hands of Muslim Students tonight they're
holding the Americans hostage it's an
extraordinary act and an audacious act
to humiliate the United States and it
was having a big impact on the American
public we were helping the American
people who understand the consequences
of the actions of their government in
Iran there was an Unholy pact between
the United States and Iran in one word
the special relationship
it seemed to me that the oil wealth
wasn't trickling down to the people and
that made me very angry the social
fragmentation the corruption that was
the fuel Khomeini was the match
ocean became a monster I thought we were
gonna have freedom they were just
absolutely convinced that we were spies
my interrogation was unpleasant let's
put it that way the hostages have been
there for almost a year now this is
going to be the basis of this election
this was fully televised and it was very
television friendly the car was
convinced that he could solve this he
never dreamed it would go on 444 days
how do you think this will all turn out
why did this go on for so long I never
thought of myself as a hero I wanted to
make it home